>> Tucker: WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
THE LONG NATIONAL NIGHTMARE IS
OVER.
WE ARE HAPPY TO REPORT.
PAUL MANAFORT IS BEHIND BARS
TONIGHT.
THE 69-YEAR-OLD LOBBYIST WAS
DRAGGED TO PRISON ON THE ORDER
OF THE FEDERAL JUDGE.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED ABOUT
MANAFORT'S IMPRISONMENT EARLIER
TODAY.
WOW, A TOUGH SENTENCE FOR PAUL
MANAFORT
MANAFOR
MANAFORT.
WHAT ABOUT?
THAT'S THE PRESIDENT'S VIEW.
ON THE OTHER HAND, WITH MANAFORT
IN A CAGE, THE REST OF US CAN
RELAX.
UNCHAIN THE DOOR.
LET THE KIDS PLAY IN THE YARD.
TAKE THE FIRST DEEP BREATH IN
DECADES.
IT'S A NEW DAY AMERICA, WE ARE
SAFE.
WE HAVE BAD NEWS AS WELL.
PAUL MANAFORT'S CRIME WAS
VIOLATING THE FOREIGN AGENT'S
REGISTRATION ACT PASSED IN 1938.
ADVANCING THE INTEREST OF A
FOREIGN COUNTRY WITHOUT
REGISTERING WITH THE U.S. IS A
FELONY.
THAT MEAN MANY OF THE PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON WILL HEAD TO JAIL.
PODESTA AND BOTH CLINTONS AND
UNNI-VISION TAKE MONEY FROM
FOREIGN INTERESTS.
THE LAW IS CLEAR.
THEY ARE HEADED TO THE BIG
HOUSE.
ALL OF THEM.
BEST OF LUCK.
MANAFORT WAS ALSO ACCUSED OF
TRYING TO INFLUENCE WITNESSES IN
THE CASE AGAINST HIM.
THAT'S SERIOUS AND POSSIBLY THE
GOVERNMENT WILL PROVE IT AT
TRIAL.
TONIGHT PAUL MANAFORT HASN'T
BEEN CONVICTED OF ANY CRIME.
HE IS STILL INNOCENT, BUT NOW IN
JAIL.
THAT MIGHT BE JUSTIFIED IF
MANAFORT WAS A THREAT TO PUBLIC
SAFETY OR ANYONE CONSIDERED HIM
A FLIGHT RISK.
LATE MIDDLE AGE WITH NO
PASSPORT.
LET'S BE HONEST.
PAUL MANAFORT IS IN JAIL BECAUSE
PROSECUTORS WANT HIM TO TESTIFY
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE SWEATING HIM.
NO RUBBER HOSES OR TRUCK
BATTERIES, BUT THE POINT IS THE
SAME.
PROSECUTORS WANT TO INFLUENCE A
POTENTIAL WITNESS IN THIS CASE.
AS YESTERDAY'S IG REPORT SHOWED,